i agree that the physical that is
whatever is measured is relational as
experiments have shown
but that must mean that there is an
absolute some non-physical
non-measurable layer of reality
underlying the physical
as you know
he's putting this in brackets as you
know to me that layer is mental but
carlo again says everything is
relational so
what is it relations and and so on and
so on that is turtles all the way down
or relationships all the way down how
does the notion that everything is
relational not lead to an infinite
regress
it's turtle salted way down in my
opinion
and i think what uh what
uh i mean
i think the basic uh
i mean i know of course uh
banana's uh
uh
uh um ideas uh he defended a very strong
version of idealism
in which
everything is mental
and
i think that the mental phenomena
are not
more
absolute more grounded more
basic more universal than
the
um
the physical what we call the physical
phenomena
in fact i think if
if there is a
dependence relation the dependence
relation is other way around
so
um
if we want to understand mental
phenomena
we understand them better
starting from physical facts and from
that deriving mental phenomena um
the other way around doesn't work in my
opinion the the other way around leaves
us the impossibility of doing science we
don't derive physical phenomena from
mental phenomena but the other way
around we do
so of the two
uh physical in a large sense
uh i don't mean material i mean physics
systems interacting heavy properties
uh
are
more fundamental in sense of the ground
better
mental phenomena i think the
the mistake of idealism is to
don't see
one of the main insight
um
[Music]
in
in
in buddhist philosophy which is that the
the mental is as illusory
in buddhist language as external world
so the self is us
less um
less um
founded as this glass or this pen
um when i think about myself the
illusion of this is the cartesian
illusion this is evident
this is immediate this cannot be
discounted
it's wrong
um
if there's anything what is evident for
me is this pen is not me then me it's a
complicated cultural construct social
construct cultural construct what i
directly know about the world is that
there is this pen
uh i if you say well there is also you
in the world i say oh yeah it's also me
and what is me i have to i have to do so
a reflection a story of thinking and if
you read the card
with the roger this idea
the card never said
that um
the self
it's immediate
he said if you start doubting then you
go through a complicated cultural
process of doubting
which is due to his culture his
philosophies
and this leads him
to thinking about the self and they
think if i'm doubting them and thinking
if i'm thinking there should be
something thinking this is thinking the
self but the something thinking is not
the self it's a symbol of the processes
that matter does in my brain
so that's why i disagree with the idea
it is
why is it that the mental states and the
self are are they equivalent in your
mind in your mind are they no they're
two different things no they're two
different things uh of course they're
two different things the self is a it's
a it's uh um
let me not define the self um
states as other than men but i think
that
um
what i said applied to both
and of course uh the card was talking
about the self
uh some people talk about mental state
in the in
i think both are
like chairs
complicated construction we use to
describe
what happens
uh you mentioned that science would be
difficult or if not impossible to do if
idealism was correct why can't we just
say see for me the way that i see
science is that science doesn't presume
a metaphysics
it doesn't actually say whether
there's an immaterial or material or
mental reality it's like a method now
people can disagree with the definition
of science
regardless why can't
idealism be correct and simply say there
are regularities to these mental states
and we see these regularities these
patterns of perception and we call that
physics
and we perform science that just as we
do or just as we currently do
and
sure sure no i
agree with you in in that sense uh um
science is neutral
uh
but if i want to use
science
what i was saying is something much more
much less philosophical if you want um
if i want you to if i want
to use science to make a story about how
mental state can emerge
from configuration of the brain i've
i have a
a path that i can follow in fact many
people are following today this path i
mean there's a big
neuroscience
uh literature
very extremely interesting which is
precisely describing how
mental states and the notion of a self
um can emerge in a in a complicated uh
sort of uh
neurological biological and evolutionary
story of our brain so
science allows us to make a story which
is incomplete but is in in the working
about how mental state emerged in the
world in the same sense in which it
allows us to make a story in which it
how is that a chair a marriage in the
world i mean how it's built by wood and
and built by a civilization that wants
to sit down and so on and so forth
while so so there's it can be done that
can be addressed by science
um
the the the the the the
the
the idea uh
doesn't block science it's a sense to
say well okay i have this mental uh
perception or whatever and and and as i
described them
but it doesn't allow
to do the same story to see how
i can
out of a pure
mental
state
necessarily
reconstruct the
the opposite world in other words
if i'm an idealistic
i don't have any other
scientific program except the one that's
already there i can
describe chemistry physics
but not the relation between the mental
and the physical
well if i am a materialist in some wide
sense in large sense because narrow
material is most it doesn't work i mean
the world is not made by stones
um then i i have an additional
program that i can do try to make sense
of mental state on the basis of physical
systems
why can't an idealist say we can still
do that look instead of saying how does
mentality or how does mind states come
about from non-mine states like that's
essentially what you're saying before
why don't we just say well it's all
mind-like it's all psychic in some
manner but certain configurations of
this mind state which
you can translate as matter certain
configurations of this matter
amplify the already existing
consciousness so you can still perform
neurobiology and neural correlates
in the same manner so why does thinking
of the world idealistically preclude
that i see it as just well you can just
say well we want to know what
configurations produce what states of
consciousness and what levels of
awareness and levels of
self-consciousness and so on
i i don't know anybody in neuroscience
that thinks oh
no that's not true there are people in
neuroscience that may think that way
maybe tononi thinks in that way of um
any almost any of the theories of
consciousness that i've found
and i've been studying this for this
channel it's like
it can be applied to the universe and
then you find that there's some low
grade level of consciousness applied to
the universe as a whole anyway at least
tanoni i think he's moving
in that direction i think he said that
his
iit i believe it's called integrated
information theory
implies pan psychism in some weak sense
either way you understand what i was
saying before i so you were making the
claim that idealism precludes this
understanding of the brain and
neuroscience and so on but i was saying
i don't see it as necessarily precluding
it because you can still study and just
say why is it that this configuration of
matter read configuration of mind states
produce a larger mind state or a certain
level of consciousness or certain song
yeah um
yeah uh i hope you don't think i'm
fighting with you i'm just telling you
what occurs no no of course of course i
know of course in fact
you're writing what you say um you're
probably right i
i maybe have not talked enough about
that um
you're you're
you're
bringing ideas together with a sort of
pumped psychism right so you're you're
you're you're
you're taking this in this direction
here yeah that's some sort of pump
psychism stuff of that way
um
i look
yeah
i'm not sure
what it means uh
to be a very weak level of
consciousness i know what it means in
tononi theory okay there's a quantity
called fee which have
big values in the brain and slow values
else
but that quantity has a
very clean
uh
quantitative value
determined by configurations of matter
and the way matter might interact
so i know that trenoni himself is a sort
of hidden secret idealist or
maybe a little bit planned psychist
but i'm not sure his theory is
because if his theory was
so
it would not be possible to quantify
[Music]
consciousness on the basis of
a specific configuration of matter a
possibility of interaction of matter so
that was here's a ground there and the
ground is uh
you know his physical system interacting
and affecting one another
and out of that he says in certain
configuration this
behave in a way that we call
consciousness
so i think his theory it's far more
materialistic that even what he would
like to think remember i was saying i'm
wondering oh there's some way in which
that's correct some way in which that's
correct we were talking about this
ecumenical quality when it comes to what
was his name taloni right when it comes
to
now i know his theory isn't this it's
not as simple as let's imagine billy
balls and they bounce off one another in
certain
complex interactions these billiard
balls model and that creates
consciousness let's imagine it's but
let's imagine it's as simple as that
then as you were saying
what's more fundamental the nodes or the
vertices
sorry
the edges are the notes
well
then i'm wondering hmm imagine tononi's
was as simple as that that is as simple
as certain belief balls and they
interact so it's the relationship that
produces the consciousness and the balls
are fundamental but then earlier you
were saying well you can also view it as
the relationships are fundamental
so i'm wondering if in that sense
see the non-dualists don't like when
they say this i'm wondering if in some
sense physicalism and idealism
can be brought together as twin sides of
the same coin yes uh yes it's a good
point then
then the question is what do we mean by
mental
right if by mental
uh
we mean
uh things going on in the mind of
people like humans or maybe
mammals or maybe
um
maybe
all
animals with neural neurons which is
larger than mammals
then
i don't think this
might be sufficient to describe what
happened on a galaxy
if by mental
we mean something that might go wrong
everywhere even when there are no
animals no neurons nothing like that
then mental it's an extremely
vague notion
which i'm not sure what it means if not
just a vague analogy
that uh
somehow
uh
that's analogy might even be useful but
uh because again um i think the naive
material is misfront i mean the the the
uh
has been shown wrong by signs the the um
sort of 18 19th century idea
that there's a perfectly
full description of the world in terms
of little stones moving and bouncing one
another pulling pulled by forces
that's not science there's physics has
moved away from that
the the because of quantum mechanics
because of field theory because of
quantum field theory and so on so forth
uh so the world is far more complicated
than that and if
if you take if in particular you take
relation quantum mechanics
seriously
you think in terms of relations and how
things affect one another
now you want to call this relative
uh
properties mental
you might but then it's an a
it's a name which is uh
i i don't see what happened what adds
um
to the
uh
to our understanding
uh
and and what's
interpreting this
so that was i think i'm an ammonium
honest in the sense that i don't think
they're two different kind of phenomena
i'm a monies like in the sense of
bertrand russell they're mental
phenomena and their physical phenomena
mental phenomena oh i see white and
there's a physical phenomena that
there's a thing moving down there i
think this is all phenomena
they all belong to the same beat class
that should be explained by we we
understand more and more about all of
them but they're not two different
worlds
so if you're telling me look at some
elementary level of this distinct
very very very general way of just
understanding about the world we have
the distinction between the two
evaporates i'm happy
yeah
but is that idealism at this point
idealism is a strong way of reducing one
to the other
uh like you know
old 90th century material has been a
strong way of reducing one to the other
um
yeah
have you thought much about the heart
problem of consciousness
yeah
so what are you believe exist
all right let's see here it's a
confusion
i think it's a confusion my my take on
the heart problem of consciousness this
is david chalmer uh
is that if you reach almost the point is
about we believe that uh there is a hard
problem of consciousness because it is
conceivable for us say to think there is
a zombie right so it seems there is a
same physical configuration but nobody
inside and that shows
that even if we understand the physique
completely there is something missing
so this is based on what is conceivable
to us so the problem of uh the heart
from your consciousness
it's a problem that comes from taking
the strong
what we find conceivable not conceivable
so the kind of
uh
intuition where the world view right now
but the kind of intuition that whether
about the world view right now is
exactly the kind of thing that science
shows wrong every step of the way
so
the
the heart problem consciousness shows
that we have some wrong intuition
because nature
has produced us
by solving the easy problem caution is
not the half of consciousness so um the
easy problem of consciousness of course
is very hard which is how the brain
works
but i am deeply convinced that if you
take a copy of me
okay
equal
same
nose same hair
same
neuron same atoms same molecules same
photons exactly the same position i'm
conscious my copy is conscious it's just
no way for me to conceive
that i could be conscious and the copy
of me could be non-conscious so
therefore if we understand how the thing
works we understand what it means what
i'm saying when i'm saying unconscious
i don't believe there's a
hard problem of consciousness i think
there's a very hard easy problem of
consciousness namely
com understanding this uh this uh
you see
we don't understand
thunderstorm
well if you if you if you talk to people
doing climate science or meteorological
science not climate science
a thunderstorm is not yet understood
it's very complicated phenomenon to
understand because there's electric
things magnetic thing chemical thing
it's all sort of rapid
and
hydrodynamics is horrendously
complicated so what exactly happened
with thunderstorm is not understood okay
does this mean that it's a hard problem
of thunderstorms no it means that this
complicated thing okay does it mean that
it's jupiter
you know the the the flashes the the
lightnings are
the rage of jupiter i mean no you don't
think there's jupiter there i think just
we just don't understand what's going on
so i see
i don't see the difference between
thunderstorms and
uh
the human mind
can consciousness
let me see if i understand this
correctly if we were to imagine
duplicating you
then
you don't know or it's it's unclear how
that duplicate
would be
not conscious
the reason i'm saying is that because
chalmer one of the strong arguments
for the existence of the
heart form of consciousness
in his book
is to say well imagine you have a zombie
a zombie is somebody that believes like
me
has the same aspect of me has the same
neurons as museum synapses as me the
same
physics as me exactly the same physics
including down to the atomic level
but there's no consciousness so he says
imagine this thing okay and look if you
can imagine that it means you can
imagine that consciousness is separated
from the physical something else
something above the physical because you
can have the same physical
with or without consciousness so this
proves it
so he proves that constantly something
separate from the physical
on the basis
of this zombie argument think that there
is a copy of you
um
which is uh there's nobody inside
there's no self person
but if they there was a um
exact copy of me i wouldn't understand
what it meant there's nobody inside they
could talk to him hey carlo how how do
you feel i mean i'm the right one or
you're the right one he could fight
about that and you know make jokes about
that of course it wouldn't make any
sense to know which ones the right and
which it was the false
um
so he would be conscious under all
possible
ways that i couldn't understand
consciousness so his proof is based on
an intuition that i don't have
the existence of zombies
now lisa mullen has a book on time as
well i don't recall the name of it if
you remember you can just say it
do you recall uh
no i forgot let's forget about that
maybe the problem with time i don't know
because plenty of books called the
problem with
at least in my head okay so lee smalling
has some views on time and i recall him
saying that it may be that time is the
most fundamental
now it might do firstly does that ring
true to you just that
okay great that's what lee thinks
prior to researching about
you carlo i was just thinking well lee
smalling and carlo bervelli lupone to
gravity great let me start to research
the quantum gravity and i was thinking
that you pretty much agree with lee on
everything because in my head you both
were the same as the popularizers of
loop quantum gravity and developers of
it however as i read order of time i saw
there was a huge disconnect between you
and him on this level so do you mind
explaining
what lee's views are on time
if you can and then where and why you
defer
yeah so uh let me start by saying that
lee and i have been
i think we did the best uh physics uh
together my best physics and his best
physics probably together
um
all the not just the beginning of flue
quantum gravity i mean the start of loop
quantum gravity but also the the the
calculations of the eigenvalues of the
area and the operator which are key
results in in quantum gravity and many
other things
um
so
uh
we we succeeded repeatedly collaborating
well and uh we
we
we have always remained very good
friends all through our life since since
a young age when we met
um so
he's i count him as a
one of my very very best friends and uh
um
however in spite of that or maybe
precisely because of that it's not true
at all that we have been agreeing
on ideas all the way through
in fact i would say even the opposite
we've been able to do physics together
precisely because we disagreed through
our disagreement
interesting uh through long discussions
no no you're wrong no you're wrong you
don't see that how can i
solitary nature
exactly
so the beauty of the
our collaboration for me has been uh
being able to learn from one another
constantly being constantly challenged
by the other person
and uh and and through that getting to
to to write down equations to do to do
calculations to put up theories and to
to get results
um
lee also think this way and lee has a
very
nice way of putting this story which i
love
once in an interview um
somebody asked him about the
disagreement with me and they thought
for a while and then said well look
if we
had
had the same ideas
then one of the two of us would have
been superfluous
and i think it's a great idea right so
it's useless somebody who agrees with
you
on everything
so that's the that's the premise um now
one of the biggest uh
disagreements uh
which has grown out
in the in in the last decade is
precisely about time
it's not so strong as
one might think uh because uh
there are a lot of uh common
um
points that lee and i agree uh i mean i
i've been quoted often to say time does
not exist but
this is easily
that's a slogan slogans are
you know you're going to take it the way
that they want and it's easily
misinterpreted
time does not exist does not mean that
we have to think about reality as just
static nothing happening
it's the other way around
i think that
um you know a static reality is time
passes nothing happened
but time passes and nothing happened
um
i think we have to think about reality
as a sequence of happenings
not a set of things
before we talked about things but if we
go into relativity into general
relativity what we actually describe in
the
it's always the evolution of things so
um even an object
the object we talked about the pen what
it really is in in my eyes at the light
of general activity it's a sequence of
processes there's something happening
it's happening now and then now and then
now and now and it's just pluses and
resemble one another and this is we call
the pen
and sorry so
to interject when you say happenings are
they the same as space-time events or is
that is that different yeah yeah if you
want a
an event it's something that is a it's a
it's just limited in space and time and
and reality is this is a symbol of this
okay
so uh
it's it's it's an assemble of events
where event means a region of space-time
but also means
a a something that is happening in that
region of space time in fact
i think what the reason spray time is
it's just happening you're right right
whatever happens in that region that's
what the regional space time is
and what happened is that there is a
field there's a gravitational field
there is electromagnetic field or
electrons whatever happens there
and if there are no electrons and no
electromagnetic field is still the
gravitational field and if you take away
the electromagnetic field there's
nothing happening there's no that
reaches place time is not there correct
so this hap this happening view of the
world is something lee is insisting a
lot and i also agree with him completely
100
we should talk about that this dynamical
aspect of all the processes not the
entities in isolation so that's the part
we agree
it's a big
part so all the people who talk about
the static four-dimensional universe
frozen time
um
a block universe
i think it's misleading block universe
is just a you know a picture in our head
of an ensemble
of of of events if i think of the story
of your life curt
it's not a block universe story of love
lies things happened okay it's a symbol
of happenings good
so it's the same for the universe
now where do lee and i disagree
we disagree about the origin of the
distinction between the past and the
future
that's the disagreement
li
uh holds on to the idea
that the past and the future are
intrinsically and profoundly different
at the sort of fundamental level
so these happenings are happening from
the
past to the future
something
the past exists fix it has happened it
is unchangeable the future is genuinely
open uh-huh interesting okay that's a
disagreement i disagree with that i
think that uh
it seems to me that our best physics is
telling us
that this
very vivid difference between the past
and the future
is not in the grammar of nature it's
elementary grammar of nature it only
comes in
at the statistical thermodynamical level
when we have a
macroscopic description and therefore we
have entropy and therefore we have
things you know
ice melting down
and
and all the reversible phenomena the all
the irreversible phenomena microscopic
the irreversibility
uh
characterizes the microscopic variables
there's no irreversibility of the
microscopic variable so the distinction
between the past and the future in my
opinion
it's only for big things an electron
doesn't distinguish the past in the
future
an atom does not distinguish the past in
the future a glass of water
with ice and water does distinguish
but the distinction is in the in the
picture
in the words
glas water and eyes is the macroscopic
description so that is that's the point
where we disagree so we
you know the philosophical idea that
it's a
the description of the world is about
happenings and not about things not
about static
we're really on the same ground
but the
orientation of this happening is this
happening oriented in time from the past
to the future
is where we disagree i think that it
comes later on
at the fundamental level should forget
about that
the laws just don't distinguish between
the two
and lee thinks that in some sense the
laws distinguish potential
so what does he say in response to
your justification for saying that it's
the blurriness that generates time or
the macroscopic states
what's his response
they say you you be you carlo
i
uh
i'm not sure in fact next uh in in
next couple of weeks i'm going to
toronto and and and that's one thing i
want to talk with him i would say tell
me exactly what why do you think it's
all
um
i my reading but he might he might
disagree with my reading is that um
the intuition of the difference between
past and future for him is so strong
um
so he's holding on to this romantic idea
of ex experiential time and wanting to
that's my reading right
that's my reading but you know he might
answer something else
okay what about janice sorry what about
julian barber the janice oh julian yeah
now i haven't had a chance to read his
book i started reading it but i don't
know what his theory is i think as far
as i got was just the history of
thermodynamics so what is the janus
point what is his theory on time and
then obviously compare and contrast with
yours
so a few coordinates here
first of all julian is a fantastic
historian of science he wrote
a big thick scholarly book on the
history of mechanics which is a total
masterpiece in my opinion
um
then he
uh
it's known for two ideas about time one
which is several
that's is mostly known for that
uh
some time ago um
his uh
idea that we should think uh at uh
at the world in a completely timeless
way just a distribution probability as
instantaneous
um configurations
and recently he came out with a new idea
uh
which is this janus point
so uh i distinguish
three barbus
bubbles the bibles the historian of
physics and which you know chapel as the
french say many infinite
respect of him i learned so much from
him
um barbara as the guy denying uh time in
the sense of
his old book on time and the third bible
which is about this chinese point
so
the second one
i was never convinced much because he
had a
complicated story about the universe
being extended in space but not in time
uh which i did not find convincing i i
we could go into that uh but this
we should not talk about that and we
should talk about the third one
and the third one this janus point idea
uh it's indeed uh um
quite uh um
intriguing
he's not the only one who has been
recently talking about sean carroll has
uh also uh
considered this idea there's there's an
increasing attention to this idea and
the idea is that
we are wrong
when we say that generically
if you take a system
generically most solutions of this
equation of motion is in equilibrium so
there's no past and future
um
it's true that if you if you if you put
the gas in a box and you close it
with a fixed amount of
energy uh
most possible solutions so where the gas
goes in long time is in equilibrium and
in the equilibrium the entropy is
constant there's no past in future
so then we have to say why the entropy
was low in the past it seems strange
the point is that the universe is not
like a gas in a box that's the main
observation that also sounds like when
we were talking about that there are
some problems with applying our limited
scale physics or when we do experiments
to the universe as a whole i think
that's where i got it from was reading
the janus point he was saying the
universe is not a box so you can't apply
the same laws of thermodynamics to the
universe as a whole yes exactly so but
there's a specific very very specific
reason for which you cannot
that
there is no equilibrium state because uh
if you think about the imagine the
universe just a bunch of particles in an
infinite space okay they can spread
forever
okay so they never get to reel
uh
to a real equilibrium
so let's consider one possible
configuration okay
of this particle okay
a generic one they would just move
somehow maybe they come close at some
point and then they disperse
so if you look at the future they
disperse if you come back there's some
moment in which they're closer and then
they disperse again
so the entropy in that configuration
okay
it's up goes to a minimum and then grows
of course there's no preferred direction
of time because you know both directions
disperse
but there's a minimum
so if you're on one side the entropy is
growing like that if you're on the other
side
like that so we just have one side and
of course the entropy is growing right
if you think a mountain
any mountains it has you know one
direction which is down in the other
direction which is up so generically
there's always one direction down over
one direction up
so the idea is well maybe we got
confused about the model of the gas in
the box and the equilibrium forget the
equilibrium maybe the right way is
thinking that generically
histories possible history of the world
evolve in some way and necessarily there
is one point which is minimal entropy
and then it goes one side and the other
this is the core of it maybe i'm
oversimplifying it a little bit but
that's a coral idea
so um
there are some
questions about that there are some
possible doubts i'm not sure is
it's really a solution of the
of of the end of of which problem of the
problem why the entropy is low in the
past
this you know
why the time is oriented because in the
in the past it was law entropy so why in
the past of this law entropy
that's an attempt to answer that
question
there is something ringing very
interesting and i think there's a
discussion going on right now
among theoretical physicists and
philosophers
uh on
should we buy this argument is it
correct um i'm interested in the
discussion
and i i hope that in some years it will
clean up
namely yes that's a good way of of
thinking
about uh why entropy was low in the past
one direction which is the one we call
the past
uh or
no come on we're getting confused about
probabilities here
you're it's
tissue is squeezing in some some
some
some intuition which is not correct i i
don't know it's a it's it's um
it's relatively recent
that
we've been thinking about that
and uh i'm i'm open to to this idea i
found it interesting
this minimum point does he say that's
the big bang or does the big bang happen
at somewhere on the up so it's still
relatively yeah in a sense that in a
sense that's what's called the janus
point because genesis is god
in in rome it's it's latin god
um which is the god of the doors of the
of the change of the ear it has two two
faces it was always
uh represented with a head with two
faces one face is this way one face is
the other way so the janus point is a
point where the future you know the one
future this way one future that way
because
the future is determined by end to be
growing so this is the minimum of the
entropy so
entropy goes this way and it will go
this way so whoever is here or whenever
you are here you see the future this way
whenever here you see the future this
way so you always see the
right the big bang in the past right
that's what you call the best yeah
interesting interesting
okay now to wolfram
which we could take out so don't worry
do you have any
thoughts on wolfram's model critiques
any
what do you find interesting when you
find not interesting convincing not
convincing
um
i
i am not uh
overexcited
by the idea that a simple classical
um
microscopical model
could uh
could reproduce
the
the complexity of the physics that that
that we see
why do you call it a classical model
because it's definite the hypergraph is
definite or what
uh it's classically in the sense that uh
you can view this as evolution in time
and at
each specific steps moment there are
there are steps uh the fundamental
variables which have
a a unique value so in that sense is
classical quantum mechanics variables
don't don't have a specific value
um
i think that to
form here
to reconstruct the complexity of quantum
mechanics in full
has not been done yet i have not seen it
uh yet
and uh i i
i doubt that one could actually
do it unless i see it in in detail there
are aspects of quantum mechanics
um
like those uh captured by uh
conscience spectre
theorem
uh
or by the bell inequalities
which are very hard to reproduce this
way notoriously very hard to reproduce
this way
so um
one might copy some aspect of quantum
mechanics
i i haven't seen
the full prediction of quantum mechanics
coming out yet